so because you read a lot of books are
there can you look back and it's always
a tough question because so many it's
like your favorite song but are there
books that have been influential in your
life
that an impacting your thinking or maybe
once you go back to that
um
that still carry inside for you the
Federalist Paper is a big one in terms
of sort of how American politics works
the first econ book that I thought was
really great because it was written for
teenagers essentially is one called the
economics and one Lesson by Henry Haslet
it's like 150 pages I recommend it to
everybody sort of 15 and up it's it's
easier than say Thomas Hall's basic econ
which is four or five hundred pages and
it's looking what like macroeconomics
that kind of stuff
um and uh and then uh in terms of
there's there's a great book by Carl
Truman called rise and Triumph of the
modern self which I think is the best
book in the last 10 years and that's
been sort of impactful on some of the
thoughts I've been having like what's
the key idea in there the key ideas that
we've shifted the nature of how identity
is done in the west from how it was
historically done that basically for
nearly all of human history the way that
we identify as human beings is as a mix
of our biological drives and then how
that interacts with the social
institutions around us and so when
you're a child you're a bunch of
unfettered biological drives and it's
your parents job to civilize you and
civilize you literally means bring you
into civilization right you learn the
rules of the road you learn how to
integrate into institutions that already
exist and are designed to shape you and
it's how you interact with those
institutions that makes you you it's not
just a set of biological drives and then
in the modern world we've really driven
toward the idea that what we are is how
we feel on the inside without reference
to the outside world and it's the job of
the outside world to celebrate and
reflect what we think about ourselves on
the inside and so what that means that
we are driven now toward fighting
institutions because institutions are in
positions so everything around us
societal institutions these are these
are things that are crimping our style
they're making us not feel the way that
we want to feel and if we just destroy
those things then we'll be Freer and
more liberated it's it's a it's a I
think much deeper model of of how to
think about why our social politics
particularly are moving in a particular
direction is that a ground shift has
happened and how people think about
themselves and and this has had some
somewhat kind of shocking
effect in terms of social politics so
there's negative consequences in your
view of that but
um is there also positive consequence of
more power uh more agency to the
individual I think that you can make the
argument that institutions were weighing
too heavily in how people form their
identity but I think that what we've
done has gone significantly too far on
the other side we basically decided to
blow up the institutions in favor of
unfettered
feeling slash identity and I think that
that is not only a large mistake I think
it's going to have Dior ramifications
for everything from suicidal ideation to
institutional longevity in in politics
and and in society more broadly